so we're here in los angeles at our
glass technology center where we make
all the prototypes for all of our
vehicles and to give you a real life
example of the acoustic performance of
our side drop just roll up the window
here
to give you an idea of how comfortable
the experience is in our vehicle
so as the designers first sketch the
model y or s and x and three they sketch
the glass from the front of the vehicle
all the way to the rear of the vehicle
and we spend a ton of time making sure
that each glass position is the right
curvature is the right size and shape in
order to give that seamless approach one
of the coolest things that we've done is
incorporate acoustic side laminated
drops across every vehicle at tesla so
what this consists of is a glass
sandwich you have a glass outer and a
glass inner and in between an acoustic
dampening layer for road noise wind
noise that the customer will experience
and make the inside occupant feel
quieter so what we have here is a two
percent tint we use on roofs and things
of that nature we combine that with
different types of thin films that have
properties like solar for reflecting
radiation and we'll combine that with a
standard pvb that has uh different
properties some have acoustic properties
others have solar properties so we have
to be very careful on what we choose
to go into the vehicle
as we look at these large pieces of
glass safety is a huge consideration so
we work with our exteriors our closures
team on making sure it is very safe for
our occupants for things like rollover
roof crush testing then we go into the
thermal aspects to make sure it gets the
best thermal performance the roof itself
absorbs 99 of the uv radiation coming in
so it's amazingly safe even though you
have this large open experience inside
your vehicle so across all of our
vehicles at tesla we have a suite of
autopilot cameras here in the front of
the car looking forward through the
windshield so in a sense our windshield
is becoming a lens in front of the
camera and we focus on things with
distortion as well as working hand in
hand with our autopilot team on
functionality heating function as well
as diffraction of the images that are
coming in and i would say it's part of
the way that we're leading the industry
and setting the standard for autopilot
functionality and the glass quality
that's required for autopilot